I have for you today possibly the dumbest segment
in news, Max. History news. Max, is one of these
sort of like a lower rent. Fox News more extreme,
by the way, if you can imagine. And this was an
interview that two news Max hosts did with Dick
Morris. I have to tell you, Dick Morris is kind of
a sad character at this point. Dick's in his mid
seventies now. He's not super present publicly,
but Dick Morris was like a big Clinton friend
in the early nineties who eventually had a
falling out with the Clintons, turned against the
Clintons, but also became kind of a right wing
apologist. I won't necessarily say he is a right
winger, although after watching this interview,
it sounds like he is, but certainly a right wing
apologist. I interviewed Dick Morris a few years
ago. He hated my line of questioning so much that
he hung up on me. You can find that interview on
my YouTube channel. So Dick Morris appears on
Newsmax right after the Colorado shooting. Now,
first of all, the segment, this segment
existing at all, aside from what Dick says,
which we will look at the segment existing is
part of the silliness. Newsmax and Fox and others,
they've been covering the Colorado shooting
where we found out the shooter is Muslim,
totally differently than the Georgia shooting,
where the shooter is white and the victims were
minorities. But I'm for this segment. I'm putting
aside the structural hypocrisy. And we're going to
focus just on what is said during the interview.
So let's jump right in and look at the first clip
murderers and their willingness to continually
make excuses for them. Your thoughts?
Well, there's a overwhelming point here, which is
that the killer was a Syrian refugee and Donald
Trump banned refugees from terror sponsoring
countries like Syria and Donald and Joe Biden has
opened the floodgates again, letting them in. And
in fact, with specifically earmarking refugees,
he's increased the number of refugees that can
come into the U.S. by a factor of seven or eight.
So Dick Morris is argument. Is that the shooter
in Colorado is exactly the type of person that
Donald Trump banned from the United States, but
Joe Biden is now welcoming to the United States.
The Colorado shooter was three years old when
he came to the United States. He was radicalized
in the United States or he became, you know,
if we want to go the mental illness route, he
developed his condition in the United States
and is essentially an American. I mean,
I came to the U.S. when I was five, so I was
two years older than the Colorado shooter. My
upbringing has been shaped here. My education is
mostly in the United States, my political views,
my interests, my social circle. It's all been
shaped here. The Colorado shooter was even younger
than I was when he came to the United States.
What on earth does this have to do with Syria or
Donald Trump's ban or Joe Biden? And if you can
believe it, it gets even dumber. Let's continue.
The other point I want to make is if
the Democrats are so worried about
gun violence, the most important thing you can
do about gun violence is to institute the stop
and frisk policy that New York City had until
the Democrats forced it to be to be stopped.
OK, so now Dick Morris says, let's use stop and
frisk. We're talking about mass shootings here,
individual gun homicides, handgun stuff. OK, like
you can you can talk about stop and frisk forced.
The problem with stop and frisk, as we saw in New
York, is its application was extremely racially
biased. But this segment is about the causes of
a mass shooting that took place with a rifle.
Does Dick think that police will stop mass
shootings with rifles, with stop and frisk,
where police just stumble across a random guy
with a gigantic rifle in his pants on his way
to a mass shooting? It's ridiculous.
And then it gets even more ridiculous
when the cop actually see somebody on the street
with a gun in a high crime area very late at night
and can stop them and see if they're
armed. If they're not, they let them go.
If they are, they get they get arrested for a
mandatory three year sentence for carrying a
loaded firearm in the city of New York.
Now, did you hear what Dick said there?
Stop and frisk is where police can stop someone
if they see them walking around with a gun. That's
not stop and frisk, that's you see someone with a
gun and you inquire as to the legal status of the
gun. But then Dick says they frisk them and if
they have a gun, they get arrested. But, Dick,
you just said stop and frisk is police see
someone with a gun and they stop them. But
now you're saying stop and frisk is if they have
a gun after you frisk them, you arrest them. It's
making no sense. And of course, its application
to mass shootings is zero. Let's look at a little
more of this. And this is funny because the
host actually says the Colorado shooter was
only three when he moved to the US. It doesn't
slow Dick Morris down, even one for a moment.
Yeah, you know, amid all this, he moved here to
this country when he was just three years old.
But because of some recent activity of his,
he was actually on the spectrum of the FBI.
So this is another case that the FBI was aware of
him or at least people near him and watching him.
But yet this was still allowed to happen. That's
another conversation a lot of folks aren't having.
Yes, well, I think the the point
is that he comes from a country
that sponsors terrorism, Syria and his parents
didn't want him here at a young age, but
that is precisely the kind of immigrant that Joe
Biden is living in and Donald Trump wanted to buy.
So Dick Morris here is the kid was three when he
came to the U.S. and the FBI was aware of him.
But he's sticking with this is why we don't let
Syrians into the country. So the real story there
is that yet again, the FBI has their eye on
someone and that individual still can get
guns more easily than you can register to vote
in some states with a waiting period on voter
registration. Right. There are states where you
can't register and vote on the same day. You have
to register in advance and later vote, but you can
decide same day to go get a gun and walk out of
the store with it that that day on the FBI's radar
and still was able to do that. But Dick Morris
says the problem is, I guess we don't have stop
and frisk. And the kid came from Syria when he was
three. And that relates to Joe Biden in some way,
I have to tell you. Dick Morris has become sort of
a sad figure in politics and Newsmax, allowing
him to also expose his incompetence only makes
it sadder, but making no sense whatsoever. And the
Newsmax host standing aside and letting him do it.
We'll have more on this. And I would love your
reaction. You can follow us on Instagram at David
Pakman show. And we will have maybe will have a
an additional clip of this interview. It's really
something to see. Find us on Instagram at David
Pakman show. Find me on Instagram at David Pakman.